I chaired the economic council.
It's called ECOFIN and it is kind of
the house of the 27 Member States.
It's where ministers
from each country meet,
where compromises are made,
and when a compromise is made,
on the basis of a proposal
from the Commission,
then we will negotiate
with the European Parliament.
It is a challenge.
You are chairing a meeting
in another language with new colleagues
and some of the issues that we are
debating are of a very complex nature.
Interplay between the President chairing
it, the colleagues round the table
and all the employees and staff
around us is very delicate.
We had a very high priority file
from the Commission,
concerning
how our financial institutions,
how banks should work in future.
There were
lots of different interests,
but there was also the momentum that
maybe we can reach an agreement today.
The file we were negotiating over
for those 10–15 hours
contained, I think, 700 pages.
So it is of crucial importance
that our staff have done their job.
We had the meeting around the table.
We broke up. Had a break.
Went into smaller meetings.
People were coming and going,
discussing it in smaller groups.
Back to the table to then figure out
how to take it from there.
And the reason it took so long
was that we said:
We are almost there now,
we are close.
Maybe, maybe, maybe
we can reach a consensus today.
We were getting very, very close.
In the end,
in the middle of the night,
we had a consensus
among a huge qualified majority
and we said: This is it.
Now we have 14 days to make sure
that we got everything right.
Negotiations always depend
on good preparation.
Knowing what you want to achieve
but also knowing
where you can compromise.